I'm Leslie curry from the Yale School of
Public Health welcome back to our series
on qualitative research methods this
module addresses qualitative data
analysis we'll look at the principles
and practices of this method just to
remind us the goal of this series is to
enhance our capacity to conceptualize
design and conduct qualitative research
in the health sciences there are six
modules in this series this module
addresses an overview of qualitative
data analysis I want to spend a moment
with this figure which I think conveys
the most essential defining feature of
qualitative data analysis it's an
iterative process of individual and
group level review and interpretation of
narrative data so we move back and forth
between the individual analyst reading
and digestion and interpretation of the
narrative data and then the research
team multidisciplinary research team
interpretation of the data and the
moving back and forth between these
levels is really critical to generating
rich interpretive analysis let's start
with an important definition what are
codes a code is a word or short phrase
that represents the essence or the key
attribute of narrative or verbal
information so for instance think back
to the module where I described a study
on hospitals who take good care of
patients who have heart attacks and
we're interested in what those hospitals
do in order to have great outcomes for
patients with heart attacks we may find
that the support of senior management
within the organization is really
critical a code might be senior
management support these codes are used
to codify or to categorize the data
coding the active coding is the process
of organizing the data into chunks that
are
like chunks or segments of the data that
are similar in important ways and then
codes are developed into a code
structure so what is a code structure
code structure is a compilation of the
emerging codes the codes that are
developed during that process of
individual and group review and
interpretation codes the code structure
includes brief definitions or properties
for each code and the code structure can
also contain illustrative quotes or
excerpts from the transcripts that
demonstrate that particular property or
definition for a code the code structure
might also include guidance for the
coders the analysts for when and how to
use the codes and really important to
recognize that the code structure will
evolve throughout the analysis we often
have 10 or 20 versions of a code
structure in the course of a given
research study so let's take a look at
an example of a code structure this is
from a study conducted by one of the
clinical scholars and the Robert Wood
Johnson clinical scholars program where
I get to teach and be a mentor
Peggy Chan was interested in the
professional experiences of
international medical graduates who are
practicing primary care in the United
States this is a topic very well-suited
for qualitative inquiry what are the
perspectives and experiences of this
very unique population and so Peggy
conducted in-depth interviews with a
sample of international medical
graduates and we had a multidisciplinary
team on the group really very important
I think to the quality of analysis here
we had an organizational psychologist
another international medical graduate
and individual of expertise in primary
care workforce issues so very
interesting broad range of perspectives
on the team doing the analysis we'll
look at the code structure from Peggy's
study this is an example of what a code
structure looks like it's very
hierarchical it looks like an outline
you might do for a research paper the
code structure labeled understanding the
experiences of immigrant physicians
really important to put the research
question embed it right into the code
structure this helps the team remember
where is it that we're going what is the
target what is the intended research
question that we're setting about to
answer with this analysis this helps
protect against drifting off and some
you know interesting new development
that you see emerge in the data but
that's not exactly relevant to the
research question at hand so hurt here
her question what are the challenges and
advantages that international medical
graduates physicians face in providing
patient care in the US healthcare system
and then you see the tags codes labels
enumerated here each with numbers so
first a first set of codes is the notion
of support and these are followed by sub
codes so these are dimensions of this
larger bucket of support so here we
might see colleagues and peers as a
source of support mentors aspects of the
training and curriculum that are
supportive and so code structures look
this way where there are sort of large
conceptual domains tags or labels and
then sub domains that further
differentiate that property you see the
different levels of codes that can be
done some relatively straightforward
support and others more nuanced and
complex so let's just take a look at
number two
this notion that medicine is different
in the US and this is the focus on
professional experiences here some of
the dimensions of this code are that the
culture of medicine is different the
u.s. in the u.s. patient demands for
technology million-dollar workups these
are some ideas related to culture of
medicine the nature of physician patient
interactions what those look like views
around patient autonomy and
decision-making and how the IMG
international medical graduates
experience that authority relationships
in the workplace so you see there's a
range of depth and complexity to codes
within a code structure so there are
three approaches to developing a code
structure the first is a purely
inductive grounded method so really
working wholly from the participant
experiences that drive the analysis
entire
we do line-by-line de novo coding
meaning every line of the transcript is
coded for an emerging idea
nothing is brought brought in advance to
the coding process this may employ
constant comparisons which is the
process of moving back and forth from
the codes to the emerging data to look
to see whether or not there are
similarities or differences and
developing the code structure to
accommodate new ideas the benefit of a
purely inductive grounded method is that
it limits the possibility of the
researcher forcing a preconceived result
coming to the research thinking well
it's all about Authority relationships
here the de novo line by line grounded
practice preempts that possibility the
second approach is a start list method
this process brings a preliminary
organizing framework to the table this
is somewhat deductive in nature because
we're coming with some organizing
scaffolding to the code structure the
initial codes are drawn from things like
the researchers own expertise what is
known about the particular topic of
inquiry the existing evidence base and
so we may come to the study with a
recognition that we anticipate certain
core concepts or codes will be in those
data and so we come with what we call a
start list our team described something
that's sort of a compromise between
these two methods a more pragmatic
approach that we call the integrated
approach
so this retains the benefits of
inductive coding so we want to be very
attentive to what emerges from the data
and yet it acknowledges that certain
code types are useful in developing
certain forms of output and so if we're
thoughtful and deliberate and we bring a
framework to the code structure we're
able to be more precise and efficient in
the code process so we begin with broad
code types and then we develop the sub
codes from the data so I mentioned in
the first slide in our first schematic
we saw the iteration between individual
and group level review we just walk
briefly through this
maduk to illustrate again the cyclical
process of coding and qualitative
analysis so we have our transcript that
enters the system and first and this is
really the most fun part is to always
read the transcript freely before coding
so sitting with nothing other than your
eyes and brain and attention and reading
the data broadly and without any biasing
or assumptions or jumping ahead to
analysis or coding spending time in the
data we then move to create the initial
codes and properties so like in Peggy's
code structure we saw support and the
various properties are defining elements
of this notion of support we bring that
initial code structure to coding two or
three of the transcripts within the data
set a cluster of them and here we're
negotiating and revising the code
structure as we move back and forth
across the individual and group level
reviews and debating and revising the
codes in order to accommodate various
perspectives in the analysis we then
bring the code structure through the
cycle using batches of transcripts to
analyze and constantly negotiating and
revising the code structure throughout
the course of data collection ultimately
the goal is to create a final code
structure that then is applied to the
whole data set systematically so that we
end with a comprehensive fully coded set
of narrative data that we can then begin
analyzing and even more complex levels
so that's an overview of the process of
coding come back to - Peggy's project in
a code structure and I want to give you
a snapshot of a real live document this
was my commenting on Peggy's code
structure one of the very early versions
and I mentioned we often develop a dozen
or more of these through the process and
this is intended this is the richness of
analysis and we're in fact generating
our findings as we go and so in a very
early version of Peggy's code structure
we have the title the research question
and then the support network
professional choices was the original
second code rather than medicine is
different in the United States so in
this very
first version of the code I offer up
some comments over here and my first and
it is always my first comment too many
codes and I usually soften this with a
smiley face because it's a comment I
give all of my students or trainees who
often will come with a code structure of
80 or a hundred codes very diligently
developed through the analysis of a set
of transcripts it's way too many to
navigate ultimately the distillation is
the job of the analyst and we need to
get there sooner rather than later and
working with a hundred list list of 100
codes is just untenable and actually not
productive and so we often will advise
we want about one single page
single-spaced
a number of eight to ten maximum codes
and usually we you know we get there as
the larger codes merge and are refined
over time but it's important not to
start with with way too many codes and
another consideration just deciding the
goals reminding ourselves again of the
focus of the analysis so that the codes
are deliberate and will inform the the
primary research question so just to
give you a flavor of what an early code
structure looks like so I think this
illustration sort of reminds us that we
need to be flexible in refining the code
structure and so we come after our
individual analysis we come to groups
where we need to have negotiations about
well what did you see in that data well
I didn't really see that they were
talking about Authority and
decision-making I saw it more as he was
describing anxiety around the patient
physician communication dynamic and so
those negotiations happen amongst the
team in those negotiations codes may
need to be expanded to encompass more
ideas you might have to refine the
properties of a code you know so it by
this code we're referring to this kind
of you know power dynamic we're not
referring to physician panic patient
interactions you may need to merge into
existing codes and so you're always
looking for logic and flow within the
code structure and being open to the
breaking out or the merging of existing
code
using software for data management this
is becoming sort of a standard in the
field there are many types of software
now for qualitative data management when
I first was trained in the 1990s we used
colored pens and color coded data spread
out over a long table we're much more
efficient these days and using the
software is really seen as as a standard
in the papers that I review in the
grants that I review I expect to see
that the team is using some kind of
software it's really essential in order
to organize large amounts of data and to
be able to manipulate those data in ways
to really enrich the analysis using
software also supports transparency in
the research process and I think this is
really very critical as qualitative
research becomes more and more embraced
in the Health Sciences there's a healthy
skepticism you know what is this process
of analysis what do you mean you know
you code and you develop themes and
having the data organized in an
accessible data set for others to be
able to access and interpret from does
support this broad goal of transparency
which i think really is very important
to the field and an important caution my
friend rhema Yetta who actually trained
me in the 90s and the first software
that was being developed then cautions
us always that software can support the
analysis but it does not do the analysis
for you so it's really only as good as
the analytic team is only as good as the
healthy negotiation and debate in the in
the team is that the software is really
simply a mechanism and a tool for
supporting those those analytic
processes so to close with a few
comments first probably the most
important caveat I can offer up
qualitative data analysis is not easy or
fast
I have students and trainees who think
I'm going to do a you know a study of 20
interviews and
going to finish it in you know a month
and a half and I often have to set some
different expectations the process of
qualitative data analysis is labor and
time intensive it requires
multidisciplinary teamwork where people
feel empowered to challenge and debate
and negotiate and this takes time it's
best accomplished with a team team of
people who have different perspectives
and bring a different lens to the data
the data collection and analysis
processes are iterative so we need to
sort of take off our quantitative
orientation hats where you know we never
dig to the data until they're complete
and we're ready to run our regression
models but here we're collecting the
data we're reading it we're collecting
more data we're reading it's really very
different sort of orientation the common
approach to analysis is the constant
comparative method I mentioned this is
the process of working back and forth
between the emerging data and the
existing code structure to make sure
that everything is accommodated within
the code structure this process does
evolve inductively throughout the course
of the study they did mention we often
do a dozen or more versions of the code
structure and it's important to document
the process and to develop efficient
procedures for coded dating and
management for data coding and
management because again to this point
of transparency the process is long
complex multifaceted and for ensuring
that we can describe the process or
accurately in our manuscripts as well as
make the study methods more transparent
to consumers of the data we want to be
very very careful about creation of
audit trails or these documentation of
processes and studies so thank you for
your attention